right ready you feeling the pressure
yeah a little bit right ready
that was something that was so straight
though what do you think
gary thanks for coming on my show i'm
really really happy to have you on my
show
yeah i'm happy to be honest i'm really
happy this is congratulations on uh
did you win this show i won it we had a
penalty strikeout and i uh i was
victorious yeah anyway look thanks for
coming on we actually are in football
goals but i will talk to you a bit about
football but i also want to talk to you
a bit about your career and also about
politics because you are quite
politically engaged and i've noticed it
because we've interacted a bit on
twitter and and you're quite into
politics and you you're really
clued up on what's going on but i wanted
to start and just ask you about ukraine
because
people on both the left and right have
spoken about how ukraine's provided a
moment of clarity
about a reminder if you like of what our
fundamental values are have you felt
that as well
i think so i think one of the reasons
over the last four or five years that
i've probably become more politically
engaged has been because of the wheat
leadership
not just in this country my
disappointment in the leadership in this
country but also internationally
obviously brexit and the fact that we've
been separated from our european friends
our neighbours people who we respect and
love and love us
who we should have a strong relationship
with and also the us obviously the trump
administration which again was
in my mind farcical
uh and so what we've seen is basically
over the last four or five years
a weaker west
that's i think been exploited uh in the
last few weeks and the ukrainian people
suffer for it out of the ukrainian
suffering comes a strengthened west
where people you know we recognize that
actually we are on the same side that we
should work together we need to
collaborate we need to make sure that we
unify and
but you shouldn't need what's happening
in ukraine at the moment for that to
happen
but there's always been that sort of old
cliche about sports and politics not
mixing it seems a bit hollow now doesn't
it because the two things have
completely bled into each other haven't
they in in recent
recent days over ukraine and the
sanctions and
and also kind of what's happened in
terms of sporting events and russia
being excluded
i think i've always felt that sport
should rise above politics and
um
even international crises that happen
however i think i'm wrong
uh i've always welcomed international
money into premier league football i've
always felt that we should welcome the
saudi arabian money the uae money the
russian money and that we should try and
through football and through sport
create what would be a better
collaborative working relationship
improve conditions for the populations
of these countries which yeah in large
part they do suffer they do don't always
have the freedom and the democracies
that we and the choices that we have
however i have to say that's been tested
enormously in this last few weeks with
what's happened with chelsea with the
with abramovich with the ukraine war the
connections between abramovich and putin
yeah government have obviously closed
chelsea down effectively at this moment
in time other than the fact they can
play football matches
my long-held view that football and
sports should try and
welcome this international money in
i feel a lot weaker on that opinion yeah
i was going to ask that about that guy
actually because um on march the first i
had look you did an ft financial times
football summit and you said you
wouldn't have kicked abromovich out of
english football and you actually said
he broke the old elite because he
brought new money in and he broke the
kind of top
tier and he kind of got and sort of
chelsea in
that was on march the first it's what
now march the 17th do you
even now do you think actually
you misjudged that or you've changed
your view i think what i was saying in
that particular interviews i welcome the
competitive nature the competitive
change english football the idea of
manchester united arsenal and liverpool
being the traditional elite always being
at the top always having the most money
i like the idea of the fact that they've
been challenged by manchester city
newcastle now obviously blackburn
historically with jack walker who's a
local businessman and obviously roman
abramovich's chelsea i believe they've
added to the to the premier league's
global appeal the competitive landscape
of the game in this country the the
quality of the football that we see but
at what cost at what cost and i have to
say i've always welcomed it
um
i welcome into international investments
into cities
but then i think the line has been
crossed and it's obviously been crossed
so you in the last few weeks so you sort
of see it as a moment of reckoning for
english football now absolutely a moment
of reckoning i don't think the premier
league could continue to bury the heads
in the sand and feel as though i mean at
the moment we don't even know where the
premier league stand on these big issues
at times they waited for the government
to act before they suspended uh
romney bromwich as a director he'd
almost already had the club taking off
him at that point yeah um the premier
league
it's it's
it's chasing them down the street
the issues around independence
transparency hitting proper owners tests
redistribution of funds looking after
grassroots football they can continue to
ignore it but it's coming for them and i
think this crisis in the last few weeks
has made it incredibly difficult for
them to ignore that there's got to be a
better way forward you know you're
talking about some of the richest
businessmen in the world states in the
world now owning not owning english
football clubs which i say it's made it
such a competitive game it's made it a
brilliant game but it's been basically
uh it's happening without control
without independence and without
transparency in our game in this country
is far too important for deals to be
done but we still don't know how saudi
arabia were accepted into this country
as a football club owner we have no idea
we know that they're in we know that
they met the criteria but no one knows
what the criteria and you would have
seen yesterday that the chelsea boss
thomas two shell made that point why is
it right for chelsea to be punished over
russian's invasion of ukraine but
newcastle have not been punished
given that saudi arabia are involved in
a war in yemen i mean there is a
contradiction there isn't there that's a
you're absolutely right and i say i'm
happy to say i'm happy to
say that i've been wrong on this
particular issue i think it's taken the
ukraine war for me to recognize that
that we cannot accept
money into football in this country
that is tainted
and there's no doubt that we have done
so gary following on from that do you
think that it should be right that the
premier league asks owners to sign
declaration supporting human rights or
there's an independent regulator
that checks these things before
people are allowed to buy clubs like
there should be more regulation of the
sector now well 100 i've been calling
for independent regulator for two or
three years and that has to come in that
has to be a priority because there is a
crisis in english football every 10
minutes you know whether it be derby
county whether it be the super league
project whether it be abramovich in the
last few weeks there is no way that the
premier the premier league have proven
that they're not fit and proper and
they're not capable of demonstrating the
leadership that's needed in english
football so that will change
um i think just generally this is a
wake-up a wake-up call i think for all
football clubs
associations organizations
that
we can't just separate ourselves from
the political and social uh issues that
are surrounding us we are intertwined in
it because of the ownership structures
that exist in english football at this
moment in time well look gary let's come
on to talking about you and your
uh
sort of interaction between football and
politics and also
just all your business interests so
let's kick off with
you know i've been reading a lot about
you the two things that have really
struck me is you're very busy
and you're very driven generally you're
very you're a tv expert you're a social
media influencer you own hotels you're a
restaurant you're a football club owner
you've set up a university you've just
joined the labour party and you get up
at 4 30 a.m and your motto is attack the
day there's this relentlessness about
you i mean for start how did your family
cope with it they don't really they
ignore me at times and just let me get
on with it actually it's the name of my
business relentless um
it's my favorite word in the world
because i don't think it does stop i
think that you have an opportunity in
life you're here for a very short period
of time i think you go for it you attack
the day you make every moment count it
wasn't i wasn't born like that it's my
parents my upbringing my coaches my
manager at manchester united surrounded
by brilliant people who set the right
example
and we have two choices when we wake up
every single day we're either going to
go for it and try our very best and not
give in or the opposite of that and for
me there's only one way to go you have
obviously you set up a university you
have a you have a business i mean you
run you manage 600 people i mean you're
you're a serious businessman aside from
all of your other interests around
football but you have said that
when you're 50 which is in three years
time it's the next phase of your life it
seems to me from observing you a bit
it's a question of uh if not when you
get into politics is that fair
i don't think so i mean i'm obviously i
joined the labour party i wanted to i
felt compelled to
i do you feel compelled to
real disappointment with the existing
government
um
we have to be better than that
we have to be better than that and i
think in the last two or three weeks
it's absolutely right that you know the
labour party liberal democrats the smp
people who comment on sort of what the
political situations have backed off
because it's important that we have
unity at this moment in time that we
concentrate and focus on what's needed
in ukraine and support those people and
not feel like let politics get in the
way of it however the baton has just
been placed on the floor it needs
picking up again do you think that the
conservative party should have a policy
now that they don't
accept any money from russian donors
unless it's someone that's opposed to
the putin regime i mean they've
laundered the money through this city
for the last 10 years they've poisoned
people on our streets
they've invested into our
current
serving government party
i'd suggest that that's something that
doesn't need to be said
i mean we need to be very light on this
at this moment in time because it takes
away from the focus of making sure that
boris johnson who to be fair doesn't
need much to distract him but at this
moment in time he needs to focus
on ukraine and making sure he makes the
rights that's why i'm leaving off him
that's why so you don't think he should
resign at the moment at this moment in
time i would say that ultimately
there needs to be a focus completely on
him doing his job which is supporting
the british government in making sure
that everything that needs to happen in
ukraine happens however the the second
that hopefully this crisis is over or it
subsides he needs to leave because he is
a danger to our country the standards
that we have got zero credibility
in europe and around the world we need a
government who can rebuild our
relationships and our standards
gary when you i mean just to be clear
they
the the government would would contest
that but of course
just to be clear though i mean
when you're when you're kind you're so
sorry
but you have a very visceral dislike for
boris johnson but you also have this
very public role as a kind of leading
football in star and commentator do you
ever get
blowback from fans that don't like it
because millions of people voted for
boris johnson of course and they don't
like you talking about that absolutely
and absolutely i've got look
they're smart operators i've no doubt
that when they get when they say get
brexit done and when they say get
levelling up it's hitting home because
they've got data behind them to support
it they socially engineer our minds
we've got to get back to what's
important in this country except
millions of people have voted for him
i'm hopeful that brexit was a big part
of that and ultimately the also weakness
of the opposition
but i'd like to think in two years time
that we have a we have a better place to
go to in terms of leaders i'm going to
ask you two more things so one just
going back to politics i want to pin you
down a bit
what about running education for the
government
in under labour government cabinet
minister
johnson i'm really passionate about
education i know you so i mean you said
i'm really passionate about education
because i do believe it should be the
heart health and education should be the
heart of every government policy so you
would maybe want to be an mp and a
cabinet minister or a national i love
the idea of having an influence in
education set up university you know
when i see two weeks ago that this
current government have gone out to
consultation
to remove student loans
from students who don't achieve a c a
are seeing
in gcce level in english and maths it
breaks my heart
20 to 25 of students in this country
currently go to university without an
english and maths level c at gcse level
yeah subjects like pe sports science
subjects like you know indeed in the
digital sector where many of the jobs
current jobs exist
um
you would be excluding people from
disadvantaged backgrounds low income
families because that's it they are not
ordinarily the students who don't have
that we we've got to change the way in
which we look at education so it seems
to me that you don't want to do the
mayoral race but
what i'm hearing is someone
that does want to dedicate their life
even more to public service because
you've done a lot already well that
doesn't necessarily have to be through
being an mp or necessarily through sort
of being in public office because i do
like the idea of my freedom i like the
idea of what i do in manchester with
guys you definitely seem attracted to it
i'll draw something i like i i want to
have a positive i want to have a
positive impact on the people that i'm
sort of come into contact with i really
feel passionate about the opportunity
that i was given
as an 18 year old by a great manager who
looked at me equally as one of the
experienced players in the team and i
think that everybody was a leader you
know you led the youth team you captain
manu you can't help it it's kind of in
you isn't it
it seems to me like it is look i i love
i want everyone to have the best
opportunity that they can sounds really
sort of
twee
and but the fact of the matter is
i'm really struggling with a look at the
chancellor beth yeah he's worth half a
billion quid
he wakes up one morning and he says i'm
going to lend people in this country are
desperately trying to afford their
energy bills 200 quid but then what i'm
going to do i'm going to make them pay
me back over five years at 40 quid a
year i don't want that type of guy but
the only way you change it is if you go
into politics gary i know but that's
honestly i think i think sometimes i can
have more influence with my twitter
follower with my twitter following now
that i can five million followers
probably yeah i'd probably have to be
quiet if i went into being an mp but
that guy there is that he's taken away
from this interview that you're not
ruling it out i'm not ruling it out i'm
also definitely not ruling it in yeah
but i do see some decisions that are
made we have mps at this moment in time
who vote for children in the first wave
of a pandemic not to eat food
that really disturbs me
okay i'm going to ask you one final
question
who would you rather work for liverpool
football club or the conservative party
oh my goodness gracious he's falling off
the chair oh
do you know something i have to say a
hundred percent
liverpool football club and just
something you know how much i don't like
them that's what i've done
i look at jurgen klopp jordan henderson
they're the two leaders in that club at
this moment in time on the football
pitch and off the football pitch they're
good men they're good people they're
honest
let's start with that shall we as the
basic sort of fundamentals of a leader
in this country and move away from what
would be the sort of shenanigans and
shambles that we've had for this last
six months all right well gary neville i
suspect i'll be seeing you down in
westminster in the future headline gary
neville's
well you see what i did there all right
thanks so thanks so much
thoroughly enjoyed that thank you